[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est jour de la chandeleur
et pour l'occasion je me trouve à la
crêperie de fontenay-le-fleury avec
jason son directeur bonjour bonjour
alors on va essayer de découvrir un peu
questionné coulisses de la préparation
d'une crêpe donc pour commencer est ce
que vous pouvez me dire pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait des crêpes ce jour-là ce le
jour d'achoura pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait des crêpes alors la chandeleur
c'est pour pour fêter le début de le
début de la fin de l'hiver on va dire ça
comme ça voilà pour représenter le
soleil par rapport à une crêpe qui est
doré et voilà doré est ronde du tournoi
cecafa vous avez des crêpes qui son
indémodable classique dans votre carte
mais souvent vous imaginer de nouvelles
crêpes il ya des crêpes du moment même
comment est ce que vous imaginez tout ça
comment est ce que vous pensez les
recettes apens alors pour les crêpes les
recettes on les a on les a piqués un peu
partout on va dire ça comme ça vous avez
les à courte ou là comme une crêpe au
sucre les crêpes au caramel au beurre
salé chez nous qui est fait maison
d'ailleurs vraiment toutes ces crapules
après on est parti un peu plus loin dans
l'expérience on a fait des crêpes avec
de la noix de coco on rajoute des boules
de glaces artisanales dessus vraiment si
des crêpes et nord on va dire ça comme
ça vraiment c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment pas mal voilà pour perd une
nouvelle clientèle un peu plus jeune
pour sortir un peu de tout de ce que
tout le monde connaît
[Musique]
et tu vas venir faire face à brackley un
peu et tu vas faire comme ça peut-être
tek tek et la retourner tu commences à
retourner quand tu rentres et non vas tu
entièrement clairement comment tu vas
voir
là tu as un retour nos fêtes et tac
[Musique]
ok
vous avez des ingrédients secrets dans
la préparation de votre crêpe parce que
je peux vous le dire
mais oui oui on en a alors nous
personnellement nous ne mettons pas de
notre farine et bio importé directement
de bretagne c'est très important pour
nous et voilà et le petit secret qu'on
aura ce serait remettre un peu d'huile
de fleur voir remporter ce côté un peu
sucré salé dans la galette d'accord et
du conte sont bons mais du rhum ou de la
bière dans la préparation d'une crêpe
tandis que ça la rendent meilleure est
ce que vous c'est ce que vous faites
tout ce que au contraire bas vous me
faites pas du tout fin qu'est ce que
vous en pensez moi je pense qu'il n'a
pas besoin sur l'a2 recettes de bassa
dépenses ça dépend vraiment des goûts à
la maison peut-être un peu de bière ou
du rhum et voilà c'est pas obligatoire
c'est vraiment fort a ajouté un peu de
vous nous on sucre notre pâte à crêpes
par contre on met du sucre ça c'est un
grand débat aussi à ceux conçus krupa la
pâte à crêpes on le sait personnellement
est-ce que vous pouvez donner des
conseils à nos téléspectateurs qui
voudrait réaliser eux mêmes leur propre
crêpes chez eux est ce qu'il ya des
conseils avoir des des gestes pour avoir
vraiment une crêpe super bonne est
parfaite il n'y a pas de secret il faut
bien faire reposer la pâte et voilà et à
voir le petit coup de main qui va avec
aussi parce que ça c'est important le
petit coup de main leur tournée trêve
c'est ça exactement soit vous avez une
crêpière ou bilik ça dépend de comment
on l appelle et vous avez le petit coup
de main en rond soit vous avez une poêle
directement et vous la faites tourner et
vous la retourne et merci beaucoup de
jeunes pour tous ces conseils maintenant
vous en saurez un petit peu plus
j'espère sur la chandeleur mais
également sur comment préparer de bonnes
fêtes
[Musique]